Sir Patrick right who doesn't insist on
being called Sir unlike sir Ben Kingsley
who does oh so then I'll just say
Patrick's Day yeah there we go so
Patrick Stewart so so Patrick's do you
feel like you must do it I know now I
want to sir when you have Brent on
Brent does as good an impersonation of
Patrick as anybody in the world really
and I've never heard of him if you
really get him he'll do Patrick Stewart
talking to Serene McAllen
and their their accents are just
different enough that it's his it's like
Dana Carvey when Dana Carvey does
characters George Bush talking to the
church lady Brent doing Patrick talking
to Serene is priceless but how does I
worry about you worry about lines
sometimes we we worry about more now of
course yeah as you get older but then
you look at a guy like Sir Patrick
Stewart who's 82 years old you're
directing episodes of Picard I mean
a
why is he why does he still want to do
this he has nothing to prove right B how
does he do it
those hours are excruciating and how
does he learn those lines right 82.
he does it because it's in his blood
he's been acting he's another one he's
been acting his whole life he got into
the Royal Shakespeare company was very
very young he's never stopped acting
he's one of the world's finest actors
he likes that he likes being mad and and
uh
you know what it's like obviously we
maybe you may don't you don't feel the
same way the set is kind of our home you
don't you don't miss the set I do I do
miss the the feeling the the interaction
the connection with with people and
being creative and coming up with things
I do miss that
um no I absolutely do miss that yeah
anyway Patrick is
an early riser he goes to bed having
known his lines he gets driven to work
so he's working on on the way in he gets
made up and and uh so we start early
with Patrick and we get Patrick's work
done with any luck by lunch or just a
little out an hour or so after lunch so
we give him the producers and the
directors the first
half two-thirds of the day and then
somebody else will finish up so he
doesn't do it have to do 13 straight
anymore
however he insisted on doing Seasons two
and three of Picard which was 13 months
straight so
did he have to convince the studio that
he was he could do this and he wants to
do this and he doesn't want to be they
went to him well of course he asked him
to do you know they pitched him a show
he said here's what I want the show to
be and then
that's where Picard came from and how is
it directing him I mean you've done it
for a while now he's he's putty absolute
putty like he doesn't give you any grief
he doesn't give me any grief no he knows
if I'm coming to him I've either got an
idea that he inspired or that he may be
missed a moment that he may like to try
or
um or he'll say I know Johnny
act better
and I'll say yeah that would be great or
his other thing which is I know how to
fix this I know what you mean Johnny
think faster